durant je vais vous répondre sur le fond
mais d'abord je voudrais vous dire que
je ne crois pas que quelques actions
isolées doivent nous permettre de jeter
l'opprobre sur l'ensemble de la police
de la république qui mène dans son
ensemble un travail sérieux important
primordial et qui permet de maintenir
l'ordre républicain
parce que la voix républicain c'est
l'ordre qui nous protège de l'ordre des
clans et donc je crois que notre rôle de
responsable public de responsables
politiques
c'est aussi de protéger ce qui nous
protège et de défendre l'action résolue
menée par la police que s'est il passé
en l'occurrence sur la place de la
république
vous aviez là un campement installé de
manière illégale organisée avec des
tentes et avec à l'intérieur de ses
tantes des personnes des migrants que
nous avons souhaité pouvoir mettre à
l'abri et pouvoir héberger comme je le
disais juste à l'instant
alors que s'est-il passé dès le
lendemain matin le ministre de
l'intérieur zéralda manar immédiatement
en voyant les images qu'il a lui-même
qualifié de choquant à souhaitez
commander un rapport au préfet de police
et à la suite du rapport remis par le
préfet de police qui recommandait de
saisir l'igpn est bien le ministre de
l'intérieur conformément au souhait émis
dans ce rapport a souhaité saisir l'igpn
ce qui est un acte important il a
indiqué qu'il en tirerait toutes les
conséquences et qu'il rendrait son
rapport public dans les 48 heures c'est
à dire maintenant dans un peu plus de 24
heures ensuite sur le fond du sujet car
il ya un fond du sujet l'hébergement de
ces personnes oui les migrants sont des
personnes qui doivent être traités avec
humanité avec fraternité et c'est
pourquoi là aussi des lendemain matin
avec ma collègue emmanuelle wargon
ministre du logement
nous avons souhaité mobiliser les
administrations pour soulever de trouver
les situations de relogement pour ses
hébergements
nous avons présenté publiquement un
premier point d'étape et dès demain
emmanuelle wargon la mise au logement et
moi même nous recevons l'ensemble des
associations qui travaillent dans ce
champ pour partager avec elles les
solutions proposées par l'état pour
reloger très simplement ces migrants
vous le voyez nous apportant des
réponses nous travaillons sur le fond et
nous sommes pleinement mobilisés pour le
respect des lois mais aussi pour le
respect de la dignité humaine et pour la
valeur de fraternité qui est une valeur
importante dans notre république je vous
remercie
monsieur du rhin merci de 7 de son oral
madame la ministre nous aimons les
policiers de la république nous aimons
les policiers arrivent vu quand ils sont
au milieu de la population
nous aimons les policiers de la
république quand ils sont bien utilisés
qui ne sont pas prisonniers de
l'ambition d'un homme qui cherche
toujours à en faire un peu plus et
d'ailleurs je ne suis pas certain que
vous arriviez à convaincre dans vos
propres rangs de la légitimité de la
pente que vous êtes en train de prendre
on a bien compris une chose en tout cas
c'est qu'en matière de sécurité publique
et de libertés publiques
le maquereau nice tu n'as qu'une mince
et une main droite
[Musique]